when the MU When the Music Stops please
chairs oh you're the you're our clerk
today thank
you well numbers of people send their
regrets for in most cases uh real
reasons um illness and and mostly when
the clerk is ready please call the
quorum chairman Pearson
here Vice chairman long here
representative
deimon represent resentative Bickford
here representative Nelson here
representative McMahon here
representative ball here representative
Panic here representative Sidell here
representative Gman here representative
LC representative
patrino representative
Perez representative
Greg representative Gibbons
representative
Raymond we have nine in attendance and
the and the Quorum would
eight yes we have a quorum we have two
interim study bills to look
at some people deem interim study is a
good way to keep the house from voting
on a bill they don't don't like they
refer to it as death With Dignity I
failed to see the dignity in it I take
the phrase interim study very seriously
it means we study it we have a chance to
look further at an issue at hand we come
back here and we vote we don't vote the
bill the Bill's gone we vote whether we
recommend that the subject is worthy of
further study or not worthy of further
study that's it but along the way good
work product can be
produced such as House Bill
1269 um it is on the subject of
restraints timeout rooms things like
that you remember representative maau uh
brought that bill to
us months
ago we saw strengths weaknesses some of
us have since seen a film on it we've
done a lot of in-depth study on it and I
asked representative Petrino to chair
the interim study committee on this
bill he has produced a
masterful report if I didn't know better
I would guess he had been a high school
social studies teacher for 40
years I missed that La you know
that and his report
is a whole page
long and he asked me um would he get in
trouble for doing it and I said probably
but since I sign off on it we'll get in
trouble together because what it does is
those who read this report with a view
of filing
legislation you know whether we
recommend filing legislation or not you
can't stop them they're going to do it
if they want to they've got a lot of the
preliminary work done for them this is a
masterful report so you all should have
received
it
um there were two meetings of the
committee there was a special viewing of
a movie the kids we lose which after I
watched it I sent him a lengthy critique
of the movie which was largely negative
uh and it said it exactly followed his
views on it he thought it was an ad I
thought it was an ad for a company
wanting to provide a service that really
didn't understand kids act out for
numbers of reasons not just the reason
where their company could make a
difference I'm not saying their company
doesn't make a difference I am saying
that kids act out for a lot of other
reasons than what their company
believes um he's done further research
many of you have done further research
so I present to the committee on his
behalf uh his report um for those of you
who have not had the opportunity to read
it I'll give you a chance to do so we'll
quickly
for
e
looks like just about everybody is
finished uh his
recommendation as you can see from the
bottom is on the one
hand um he believes the chapter 126 U
limiting the use of child restraint
practices in schools and treatments
facilities um was appropriate as we have
it however he saw that there may be
future legislation regarding cameras in
seclusion
areas um
camera issues may need to be
uh looked at in legislation because of
the opposing virtues of uh privacy on
the one hand and making sure that uh
testimony of that teacher beat up the
student is not verified by uh the camera
showing differently so there's that one
issue the whole issue of cameras and
investigations and also the possib
possibility that we may have a willing
School District or two to Pilot uh
different what might be considered best
practices uh before any further
legislature so his report is before you
um I will be submitting that as the
committee report if it is so
voted
um any discussion on the report which
will be his motion yet yes we recommend
further
legislation
hi representative
grossan thank you um chairman
Pearson um having done some work with
trying to get cameras on buses on
special education buses and um things
like that in the past I know that this
is important
work but there are also those privacy
issues and the ACLU was very active when
um the bus issue came up as well but one
of the overriding um messages of this I
think is the importance of best
practice and encouraging school
districts um to consider other methods
of you know
um methodologies to help work with our
kids and our populations that that need
this um and one of the main concerns I
believe for these kids is that a lot of
times these children are not kids that
can report back to
you I'm the parent of one of those
um and
so it's our duty to protect our kids you
to keep privacy I do not believe in
putting cameras on teachers um as was
body cameras as was suggested um but I
think that this
report is like you said very well done
and
um I would recommend this report um with
the recommending of best practice
disuse um and possibly working with
individual school districts to work in
seclusion rooms the motion before us
will be simply do we recommend this
topic worthy of future
legislation I do yes anyone else wish to
report representative panck thank you
representative uh
Pearson uh my son was a a loyal police
officer and when they first started
bringing in the cameras they did not
like the idea they are so grateful to
have these cameras because it avoids a
lot of unnecessary lawsuits so I think
this also
protects the teachers as well as the
students so I'm in favor of something
like this that's it thank you
anyone
else representative
bigford hey far away from his name
plate wait what is that right no uh well
unless you wish to be Perez uh no but
it's the next one up is Bickford you can
be Hispanic or you can go to L and be
French or you can be
Bickford yeah um when we left off on the
bill I recall that uh most of us didn't
really want to go with the first part of
the bill which was about filming in the
classroom and then it moves on to the
filming in the uh solitary area uh which
I think was cordoned off or sequestered
from the rest of the
classroom and I didn't have any problem
with that um is there any way the report
can say mention that because I didn't
think anybody wanted the classroom
camera so it would be misrepresentation
if we just broadly said yes this thing
should be uh completely passed we're not
recommending any of these things this is
his simply his committee report what we
are voting on is whether we think there
should be future legislation we are not
giving the content of the future
legislation
itself future legislation on the whole
thing would be no but on part of it yes
am I missing something yeah you're
missing the breadth don't overthink this
don't overd detail this should there be
we recommend future legislation of
whatever on this subject of restraints
or should there be no um future
legislation on the subject we're not
saying the details oh okay the
recommendation is yes to Future
legislation or no that's all we've got
we're not vote rev voting the bill the
bill is gone he's discussing that's I
know but somebody's going to pick up and
utilize it to get through why not
somebody can say to the contrary look
look they they've agreed to use cameras
in the classroom who did nobody has
no no it's not what this is this is
interim study it's not committee voting
on a bill the Bill's
gone okay okay representative uh
grossen just to speak to what
representative Bickford they do
recommend to what you were saying about
how the discussion of not Universal
classrooms but that it's
designated one compromise one possible
compromise may be to permit cameras only
in designated seclusion areas that's in
the end of his I think that's what
you're speaking to right yes okay there
is a recommendation within that maybe
not representative D
chairman I fear that we're going to lose
the the act of which we are um
commissioned to do in this
case um we are to here decide whether
this committee report is conducive to us
stating and only stating to refer for
future
legislation whatever that legislation
may or may not be will be decided in a
Committee hearing and vote at that time
we're not in this report trying to tell
anybody that they should create
legislation and if they decide to do so
what that legislation May
mean my reason
for um agreeing to interim study I had
many one of them was there was no fiscal
note on the bill we
cannot go against our
constitutional uh 21A 21 28a oh 28 which
is no funding no
mandate I it would have been an unfunded
mandate for the state to say you shall
have
cameras that was the first thing that I
had a problem with the second thing that
I had a problem with was putting cameras
in various areas of a classroom of a
school May envelop kids who are just the
average student doing nothing wrong
going from one classroom to the next and
it may or may not be
useful the other thing that was never
discussed is the kids
who would benefit from a video of their
situation at the moment that caused them
to go there yet the bill itself didn't
speak to that and those kids may be
nonverbal they may be verbal but not
able to express themselves at the moment
so forth and so on so there were too
many conundrums as I saw it and that's
why I thought interim study would help
during the
study my questions really went
unanswered so if there is future
legislation that's not what we're
deciding today we're saying sure why not
if somebody wants to do it let them do
it and we will debate that once the
legislation is written so this is pretty
much a synopsis of our many meetings
concerning the subject um and and we
were all wholeheartedly in agreement
with uh representative
petrino's uh report so that's all I I
hope I helped
you you understand where this report is
really going it's not going for to
suggest future legislation it's pretty
much saying sure if you want new
legislation have it we'll debate it at
that time if you don't no
problem any further discussion on the
report chair would entertain a motion to
vote Yes we recommend future legislation
who will make that motion representative
I'll make that motion deimon
representative long you want to Second
it all right any further discussion uh
when the clerk is ready please call the
role chairman Pearson yes Vice chairman
long yes representative deimon yes
representative Bickford yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes representative ball yes
representative Panic yes representative
Sidell yes representative grman yes
representative
LC Petrino Perez Greg Gibbons and
Raymond are not in attendance that's 10
y
and you can turn one of these in uh
representative ball to uh the committee
um
assistant
um Special K to
um be one of them has to is a is the
report that has to go in officially I
don't know whether there's one that's a
keeper in the folder but whatever the
clerk does to say we've just passed
something okay that ends our work on
1269 um we go next to
1590 and open the work on that that is
relative
to
[Music]
um all right let's get the right folder
relative to the training regarding child
abuse and neglect for licensed
Physicians advanced practice nurses and
physician assistance it was he House
Bill
1590 and representative long I believe
you chaed that
subcommittee uh I did and uh you looking
for a motion
uh I'm looking no at first I'm looking
for a discussion so your report and uh
does everyone have a copy of his report
them
three
four and one for the kitty I'll give the
kitty the one one for the
so if I may uh yes please make your
report so so there was a group um what
what first got me to bring this uh Bill
forward was uh there was a group working
on something like this outside of us uh
they had called me um actually was two
or three days prior to you deadline for
submitting bills and I agreed to sub
submit a bill that just made sense to me
um as we had the hearing uh there was
some confusion on uh training um there
was also some mention of
um some of the uh like some of the
Pediatrics had concern about who would
be responsible for overseeing this um
those those were all questions that were
put in the air that we weren't ready to
qu to answer those questions that's why
uh I recommended the interim study uh
and it and in that there's
um there's still
some work that needs to be done
on whether this goes to your license
whether this is just a legislative
change um where we would require it what
would be the
um what would be the
training um how would you be able to
access that who would be responsible
again for overseeing this um and who
would be required actually I got an
email from another entity and I can't
recall them off hand that also wants to
be included in the training um they want
their people an association that wanted
their people to be included in this
training um
so um
yeah was it's pretty basic uh I'm what
I'm looking to move whatever the Motions
needed is recommended for other
legislation okay anyone wish to speak to
representative Long's
presentation representative McMahon
thank youman representative specific to
the that you provided us um when it
states the minimum pH of positions only
taking the available training within
that available training is there none
identifying
abuse well at this time is yeah they
yeah it's not necessarily abuse there's
training available now and there's a
minimum of uh Physicians that are
currently taking them
not not saying that those that aren't
taking it are bad uh we don't know what
that reason is all we've identified is
there's a minimum that are taken it and
then one followup follow up okay then
just within the bill when it states
voluntary versus required that's what
you want to have additional legislation
on is requiring correct that would
include specificity correct on the
subject matter yep correct thank you any
other questions representative Nelson I
don't have a question I just had some
representative Nelson for a statement uh
I um we heard feedback that um you know
doctors learn about um what the
definition of child abuse is on in
medical school and training that they
have um when they're preparing to be on
their own as a doctor and I think that
something uh some piece of legislation
needs to be established because um as we
know you know the different definitions
of abuse um vary across the states we
don't know um where these people have
gotten their medical training and also
um continuing education because
legislation continues to change so um
you know I was really really um deeply
affected by the testimony of the two
doctors who told us about two infants
who were
um who were Chang changed for life
because the first time the abuse wasn't
reported and if it was reported maybe
there would be different outcomes for
those children so um I think that it's
really important that we continue to
um figure out what type of wording we're
going to use in legislation so that we
can have this happen any other Committee
Member representative
Grossman thank you chairman
Pearson um I absolutely think that this
should uh be recommended for further
legislation um but I received some
information from that group that there
is a potential pathway and it's through
lure um and if I can just read for
suggested future legislation
um the New Hampshire chapter of the
American Academy of Pediatrics has
written a letter requesting that
education as outlined in HB 1590 be
mandat
and this has been supported by the New
Hampshire Academy of family
practitioners there is already an
established pathway by which such
training could be made a mandatory
condition for lure this is how training
in opioid prescribing was made
compulsory several years
ago um despite the meeting with the
Board of Medicine the Board of Nursing
and the office of Prof professional lure
and
certification these entities have not
taken action yet so there is a way a
pathway and the subtleties what we're
hearing right now
about babies with broken bones the
subtleties that can happen in a
conversation where a
pediatrician a nurse needs special
training to be able to identify I mean
these are close held secrets in a family
um so if the possibility of going
through lure for future legislation um
because this is
important training that needs to happen
I believe thank
you anyone else in the committee
representative
dmoney thank you Mr chairman I too agree
that uh all medical professionals should
be well trained in the area of um
recognizing child abuse uh and being
aware of their New Hampshire state
laws in so far as what we
consider uh child abuse many many
Physicians come to our state and
thankfully so and they are aware of
other states um regulations on child
abuse and what constitutes child's abuse
and what does not uh so I think this
training could only assist assist those
Physicians I think that one of the
issues in that I had well I don't think
I know that one of the issues that I had
in this bill is it wasn't specific
enough as to what that training would be
in so far as there are so many um
trainings out there and many entities
offer training we needed to I believe be
more specific as to the criteria that
that should be met in this law as to the
training that Physicians Physicians
assistants and any other medical staff
should Avail themselves of uh so it it
it's a lot of words to say that it's
very simple to recommend this for future
legislation but be more
specific that's all I'm asking for thank
you Mr chairman is there yes
representative Bickford um yeah I I feel
the same exact way as representative D
Simon um there was a lot of hours that
doctors's going to spend according to
the bill um learning about something
over and over again it was a repe their
training was
repetitious and um I I know I've never
been to a doctor's office that they
weren't concerned about any kind of
abuse including including me you know
are you safe at home those things um
so and I feel the
it's end run around the regulatory
process that we we do through uh 551a I
think you know give the authority to
regulatory um
uh uh setting the standards and such by
them if we don't think to doing it right
then we do the end run and make
legislation over and above their uh
regulations and I just didn't hear any
of that I
you know I
mean do we even hear from can't remember
if we hear we usually hear from
Dartmouth but I'm not convinced that the
regulatory process is broke down and
when I when I am and that is the right
time to
overstep the uh regul regulatory uh
boards in fact I I saw a lot of stuff
coming in this year that was just
plucked out of the
regulations and uh waste of time
so I'm not in in favor of going forward
with
it representative Nelson thank you Mr
chairman and I'm sorry I'm a little out
of practice I don't think I said Thank
you Mr chairman when I made my last you
buy a book of five and thank me
profusely several times and then you're
good for the rest of the day how's that
okay thank you and I apologize again to
the committee too sorry about that um
while I agree with what representative
Bickford is saying um and you know
certainly we you know want to make less
laws than more
laws
um we did hear about
um children being hurt or
killed and I don't want to sit and wait
for another year or two or three years
to
see if self-re ulation is going to
change
that anyone else on the committee second
bite of the Apple representative D
Simon thank you again Mr chairman and
and I apologize um for if anybody thinks
this is a waste of time um my daughter
is a or was for 12 years a pediatric
nurse uh at Children's Hospital in
Boston my da is hearing
impaired my daughter was in the
emergency room one day when parents came
in with a an
infant and the infant was um on its
route to being diagnosed with failure to
thrive when my daughter being hearing
imped and that's why it's relevant to
this um discussion she was watching over
at the parents and she reads
lips she saw one parent telling the
other parent gez I wonder if um they're
going to be able to find out that uh
I've been doing cocaine a lot even
though I'm breastfeeding
him so anybody who knows much about
cocaine is when you put it in your mouth
um your mouth goes
numb and that was one of the reasons
that this child could not
suckle the child was now or the infant
was now losing weight because the infant
could not suckle they tried to bottle
blah blah blah so my daughter saw saw
this and she looked over at the doctor
and she said can I see you outside for a
minute please they went outside the room
she said can we do a toxicology on that
baby and the doctor said why would we do
that I didn't prescribe anything I don't
see anything in the record of this baby
receiving any medication she said could
you please just do it the doctor typical
of most doctors listened to the nurse MH
and
said why not I can't figure anything out
know doctors practice nurses do will do
it they did it they found cocaine in the
baby system it was child abuse the
baby's life was saved my point is that
it's you know we put doctors and in most
cases rightfully so on such a high
pedestal and they deserve it in most
cases but they're
human and maybe an update of this is
abuse that's abuse the other thing is
abuse will help the doctors I don't see
this as punishing a doctor or trying to
take time out of a doctor's life I see
it as assisting a doctor to do the job
that they honestly want to do as well as
they can possibly do it would have there
have been no normal protocol call when
an infant presents with failure to
thrive to do a talk screen not always
from what I hear um they go through
multiple steps in the treatment of the
infant and that could be a part of it
I'm not a doctor so I couldn't tell you
but I do know that it my daughter seeing
what that person said And discussing it
with the
physician um created a situation where
the child wouldn't have to go through
enough or or too many tests and so forth
and so on and luckily the one test that
they did which
was less invasive than many others
worked but again I just think that
doctors nurses
Pas uh and and so forth they work so
well together it's it's a great thing
but again they're human they something
could be missed and we can't afford
to be laxidasical about that and just
say it is what it is we have to at least
afford them the ability in their um
retraining uh every so many years and
they do have to um to do some of that
every so many years every year every
year or and in this case it would be
every two years they have to do it
anyway this can be just incorporated in
one of those training sessions is all
I'm
saying I'm going to take the authority
that the chair has
and ask if there is anyone in the
audience who would make no more than
three minute
presentation in favor of our
recommending for further legislation you
get three minutes no more don't Deep
dive just give us
State who you are and what your
credentials are if you wish you don't
have to do that anyone wish to do that
this good morning Mr chairman my name is
Wendy Gladstone I am a retired child
abuse pediatrician I'm one of the
people who came to you last January with
suggestions for this
legislation um we recognize that house
bill 1590 is not going to go anywhere um
but we feel very strongly that
legislation is needed to address this
problem as pointed out Physicians nurse
practitioners and physician assistants
want to do the right thing but many of
them do not understand how to evaluate a
child for the Poss ability of abuse they
don't know that we provide in this State
247 help from a system of Specialists
who can help them out when they get
stuck um they don't understand how the
laws in New Hampshire work even if they
were trained in this state but certainly
because many of them were trained
elsewhere as has been pointed out since
the original proposal of House Bill 1590
there has been written a 2hour
self-paced online free continuing
education course for Physicians and
nurses and physician assistants which
gives them the credit they would need to
have two hours completed every two years
Dartmouth is willing to give to the
office of professional Li Insurance
certification notification of which
people have completed that training um
so there's a system in place for it to
all happen it wouldn't cost a medical
provider anything and it would be part
of the education that already require to
have however we've had this propos we've
had this course available we've sent out
announcements to 5,000 providers and 60
of them have taken the course so clearly
there needs to be some sort of impetus
to get more people trained in this and
needed have you approached oplc with a
presentation suggesting that through
licensing um something is more than
encouraged yes we spoke to the office of
professional lure they deferred to the
Board of Medicine and the Board of
Nursing the Board of Medicine and the
Board of Nursing have not taken action
despite the fact that we presented to
them with the same information we
presented to you which is that children
are being injured and are suffering and
in some extreme cases dying because it's
not recognized that they're being abused
and they're being returned to abusive
environments uh representative Gman for
the
witness thank you chairman Pearson um so
would you suggest that that two-hour
training going forward maybe for next
session since we already have an online
training it's just getting providers to
take it to access it if they're required
through lure
they'll take it is that a
suggestion that you would make or that
specific
training our recommendation would be
that there be a requirement for two
hours of training that's accredited
meaning that it follows evidence-based
practice and that it covers the topics
important when I go to my family
practice physician for my annual
physical I consider what I'm given is
substandard not because of the training
of the practitioner not because of her
sincerity because she tells me she has a
limited amount of time she shall use no
more than that unless I
code might I suggest that another place
to
attack is those for-profit medical
facilities that say to Young doctors who
will practice with these huge groups
because they've got to pay off their
student loans that maybe a 15minute
visit for something or a 45 minute
annual physical is malpractice on its
face and it may not be allowed in this
state um the only reason I get good
Medical Care is because I'm part-time
CEO of a medical facility by law my wife
cannot treat me so I go outside and I
have changed doctors several times and
when I say to them you know this is not
enough their response is we
know and maybe certain things that are
missed wouldn't be missed if they were
allowed to treat the patient the way the
patient needs to be treated and not the
way the people sign the check demand
they do it
somewhere that might be a line of attack
because people who don't spend much time
miss things that they were trained to
see so if they're going to look for this
what don't they look
for um thank you for your testimony does
anyone have a question to the
witness saying none thank you again I'm
it is important that Physicians nurse
practitioners and Physicians assistants
with direct contact with those of tender
age know the signs to look for having
done a spot check of medical schools I
can tell you that this is on the
curriculum everywhere I looked having
done a spot check with Physicians nurse
practitioners I've not spoken to any
physician assistant I can tell you that
without exception each person has been
trained in what to look
for um that they've received the
training that they don't need further
training they also indicate and believe
me I live in a house with this there are
required CMEs continuing medication
medical
education hours each year lots of them
which one is you going to drop in order
to put this one in are you going to to
add two more
hours to people who already come home
tired from a long
shift and now face more medical
education credits that have to be done
by a certain time where will these extra
hours come from it's not a matter of
money it's a matter of time and
extremely busy and very tired and
overworked
people a
physician serving in the New Hampshire
House of Representatives said to me that
a the Hampshire based study indicated
that while further training might
improve knowledge about recording
requirements there is no evidence that
this actually happened that the number
of reportings actually went up when
another group of people took continuing
ed in other words if it made a
difference it didn't show up in the data
another physician wondered if there was
training in existence that has a
demonstrated
evidence-based Effectiveness in other
words sounds good where it has been done
is it
working
um I wrote down here doctors should be
required or should
be people employing Physicians should
not be allowed to let doctors do SUB
standard care
because of the clock maybe that is the
approach maybe more would be seen and
not missed if they could have the time
to look
over um so for that reason I am a no on
this I think a lot of good stuff has
been brought up I don't think the
problem lies with
legislation uh unless the legislation
has to do with hours a doct or minutes a
doctor is allowed to see somebody is
there anybody in the audience who would
this okay so that's my Minority Report
I'm going to vote no not because
of I don't care but because I don't
think this is the way to do
do representative law talk me out of it
yeah well I'm not going to talk you out
of it but my 18 years as a State Rep
this I've seen this all too often the
two the two the two constituents that
get
sideline are elders and
infants and I'm hearing you know there
they already busy they got the extra
hours those are the people that could
speak but we also heard
that children are dying children are
being abused more uh because of no um we
haven't identified it whe whether they
wanted to or not um so I you know I mean
I'm I'm even looking at this curriculum
to you know how do I deal with
detectives how do I deal with the child
advocate Center how do I deal you know
those could all make it easier for or um
for a doctor you know cuz okay if I
report this I'm going to get a call from
these three entities how do I deal with
them so there's there's time I'm
spending on that um so I think there's a
way with which we could
um be assured that they're all trained
in the way we believe they ought to be
trained and that belief would be in a
quicker uh quicker addressing um uh for
the child development purposes uh that
the child's being neglected or
abused let me let me dialogue with you
if I may um some of the children that we
don't have a pediatric practice but we
do have young adults who come in who are
in homes with their
parents and we have
seen abuse and duly reported
it and as we looked at our records we
discovered we haven't seen this person
in 3
years and the abuse could have happened
in that period of time and let's say
that person didn't come in 3 years later
but abuse started in because the person
didn't come in didn't come in didn't
come in didn't come in and now there is
abuse it sure ain't the doctor's fault
in this case so I am wondering if the
scope is not J that Physicians need to
be trained but football coaches and band
Masters and other people who in the
schools may have more contact with
children and are more much more likely
to see abuse and neglect than a
physician who might see the kid annually
if we're lucky would you suggest that
that's a uh broadening where we to go to
Future legislation yeah I I I think what
we're addressing is uh medical experts
people that are in the health industry
coaches
aren't um other people aren't so I I you
know so I so I'm not uh I mean I I don't
believe that's debatable it's it's you
know and a further if further you want
to set up some training for coaches go
for it uh I'm looking at the touch and
base on uh the medical experts um that's
that's what I'm looking to gain here at
the very
least well with two people not of my
political iCal party but have MDS at the
end of their name um telling me they
don't see the value of this but they do
see um other people with much more
regular children contact I wonder if
this is going any effort that's going
into this is going in the right
direction so that's just my response
representative
Grossman can I pass my turn to
representative Nelson who was so but to
piggy back I'll just she had her hand
up to piggy back on what representative
long was
saying representative uh chairman peon
the sources you went to were
Physicians those are the people were
asking were requiring this training of
so
in both cases they retired this would
not be for them but what about the
kids and I agree and we're not talking
about a broke you
know abuse we're talking about lives
uh-huh kids that die mhm I agree so if
we know that there is training that
we know that child and
exists why would we not want to do
everything in our power to prevent
it I would want to suggest that I have
we had did not see any data that would
say for
example when it was discovered this
child had been
abused some of the broken bones clearly
years and the child had been seen by a
medical
provider during that period therefore
they missed it versus this broken bone
is 2 or three years old and there was no
record of this child having gotten
medical assistance during that period in
other words I want to see what is the
the extent
of the problem being medical providers
missing something when it wasn't in
front of them to miss or see because
otherwise we are saying they in this
case missed it they didn't have an it to
miss But the teacher did the coach did
that's what I'm saying representative
Nelson thank you Mr chairman um actually
this is a good segue into what I was um
planning to say my husband is a hockey
coach um my son is involved in a hockey
program that is a part of USA Hockey my
husband has to take several hours of
units uh of uh training and education on
all sorts of things safety within the
sport um identifying abuse
um etc etc um every year every year to
be recertified as a coach for USA Hockey
so personally I do not think it is over
and
Beyond
what um what should be expected for a
doctor to spend two hours every two
child um we know that there are several
advocates see groups that are
also asking for additional mandated
cus to prevent other horrible
things and I am
suggesting
um how many hours of
ceu should be mandated more than what we
have now because these others that I've
heard have made a good case face
too representative Bickford thank you Mr
chairman um the what uh represent Nelson
said is it's not is required by a
certification which is a regulatory
board as I pointed out okay and not by
law so you know that coaching stuff is
done without a law MH and I'm concerned
that we're not utilizing the the
regulatory boards or those that are want
this sort of thing more hours which are
sometimes arbitrary are they actually do
you really need that much I don't know
so why would I legislate it you let the
people in the know that have the
knowledge to to do the regulations and
that's the whole point of a board
representative long uh thank you Mr
chairman so the bottom line here is we
don't have the people present we need to
talk to that's the insurance companies
okay because the time allotted to
doctors the insurance says here's what
time you got all right and they're not
here represented so the bottom line here
is a matter of the best interest of the
child the best in their development uh
and
not and not asking them because the B
not asking them how much time they have
because it's the insurance companies
that have given them that time would you
Advocate criminalizing Insurance
companies oh
yeah represent resentative D Simone
thank you Mr chairman I I I'm going to
align a little bit more bottom than uh
representative long and here's the
bottom line as far as I see this leg
future legislation this is not
legislation that is geared
to uh
discipline a
physician this is not an attack on a
physician's knowledge
or
capabilities this is simply because in
we all know that our laws change
frequently specifically could change on
an annual basis now if we find that this
issue is child abuse this
year and a physician doesn't have the
time and I'm going to go into the time
element to check
online all the laws that we have passed
or not
passed this twoyear update will assist
the physician that I have full
confidence wants to do the job well they
want to have the information necessary
to protect their patients this
legislation if it is done correctly in
the future
could assist the Physicians not attack
them I I don't believe that any
physician is out there to not do their
job I think that this is going to enable
them to do their job better I I just
think that we have lost five children in
the past couple of years due
to neglectful abuse on other
aspects uh on through state
agencies not through doctors they're
trying and I think they need our help
and I think a 2hour update every two
years may
be difficult for them but I don't think
it's too much to ask when we could have
a child live beyond the age of three or
five which is two of the specific deaths
that we've had in the last two years so
that's why I I don't see the harm in
else representative sidel thank you Mr
chairman um I just wanted to add um I
was in a Christian band for 13 years you
were where in a Christian band for 13
years in my church okay one of the
requir ments for me to remain in the
band and all of us in the band was every
year we had to take a an abuse course so
we could recognize abuse and how to deal
with children in order to just sing
voluntarily um so this I see as one more
tool in the toolbox to help our
physicians not hinder them that's all I
say
Okay would somebody make a motion or did
you already make the motion
you move I moved recommend further
legislation okay representative long
moves
further and who's seconding it I'd like
to Second
representative
Gman with the clerk please call the role
chairman Pearson having made my points I
vote
Yes Vice chairman sorry Vice chairman
after listening to the chairman I'll
vote
[Laughter]
Yes uh representative
Theon after hearing the chairman loud
and clearly I vote Yes representative
Bickford representative Nelson
passionately yes representative McMahon
yes representative ball yes
representative Panic yes representative
sidel yes representative
grman yes representative L Pino per no
I'm
sorry uh Perez Greg Gibbons and Raymond
are not present so the vote is 10 Z 10 Z
and representative long if you would
turn in your report with the motion we
recommend further legislation and for
the record I stand by everything I said
but I also stand by everything you
said and in the narrow Focus that's why
I voted yes in the broad Focus we're
just beginning on
this so whoever is going to be
on the group that files
legislation make it narrow and make it
broad folks who are you pointing
to yeah B you guys already got your team
formed good good then I don't have to
come and testify before
it well we're done and we're done for
two years those of you who are running
for the house again best wishes uh if
anybody happens to be running for the
Senate
instead uh best
wishes thank we need our plant over in
The Other Place goodbye we do be that
and those of you who are not coming back
it's been a joy to serve with you for